just about an hour ago the ntsb
announced it is stepping in to help the
investigation into that deadly crash
joel mohler joining us now live from
north las vegas with what was discussed
and what is next joe
that's right the ntsb held that press
conference here at city hall just a few
hours ago to explain that they will be
conducting their own investigation this
is separate from what the police
department is doing they will be looking
into how speed play to factor into this
crash and to provide recommendations on
how to avoid these crashes from
happening again in the future we were
out there at the intersection where this
all happened when their crews arrived
while we were trying to piece together
how this all unfolded
the ntsb arrived to the intersection
monday morning to help north las vegas
police look into the crash that killed
nine people saturday afternoon many
people are now scratching their heads
wondering how this crash was so bad the
driver of this challenger was going
north here on commerce where the speed
limit is only 35 miles per hour
according to officials he got to this
red light at cheyenne and ran right
through it that challenger was going
over 100 miles per hour according to
police when it went through the
intersection hitting several vehicles
including a toyota sienna band with a
family of seven the impact here at the
intersection of cheyenne and commerce
was so intense some of the vehicles that
were hit were pushed into the empty lot
of the northeast corner of the
intersection north las vegas police
released photos of the vehicles involved
you can see how damaged they were many
of the vehicles were unrecognizable the
investigation markings are still on the
ground the intersection is now back open
but despite that the investigation into
this deadly crash is far from over as
loved ones grieve the loss of their
family time will hopefully provide more
answers into what happened
the investigation is continuing whereas
there's still a lot of information we're
waiting to get like how long exactly
this light was read when
this the person ran this how and whether
or not this driver was under the
influence at the time as far as
e-n-t-s-b they will be here in north las
vegas conducting their investigation for
about a week reporting live in north las
vegas this evening joe mulder live local
now